after decades in the shadows there's a
resurgence in studies looking at the
potential use of psychedelic drugs to
treat a variety of psychological issues
back in the 1950s tens of thousands of
patients were treated with psychedelics
a 1966 CBS report called LSD the Spring
Grove experiment looked at the treatment
these strange images and sensations are
part of the experience of the drug
called LSD but this scene shows LSD as
it looks and sounds far from the glare
of the headlines in serious medical
research the late 1960s saw a dramatic
shift in America's views of psychedelics
the research was halted and erased from
mainstream medicine Michael Pollan is
the author of five New York Times
bestsellers including The Omnivore's
Dilemma his new book is how to change
your mind what the new science of
psychedelics teaches us about
consciousness dying addiction depression
and transcendence Michael good morning
and we must add this conversation is not
an endorsement of the use or
experimentation with the illegal drugs
for medical purposes so Michael why this
topic how did you get started why did
you get into this I was I was reading
some of these studies which I thought
were frankly so crazy and implausible I
mean people who were dying of cancer
struggling with depression and anxiety
and fear being given psychedelic drugs
psilocybin specifically which is the
ingredient in so-called magic mushrooms
to help them deal with confront their
mortality and that seems so odd to me
that I wanted to explore what it was
about and I started interviewing these
people and they had had these transform
a single guided psychedelic session in
other words they're with someone the
whole time they're wearing eye shades
listening to music they would have an
experience where they went into their
bodies confronted their cancer looked at
what would happen to them after they
died had these powerful spiritual
experiences and they emerged having lost
their fear and anxiety in 80% of the
cases in conversations about legalizing
marijuana advocates often had to fight
through the sort of Cheech & Chong's
action of marijuana talk about in this
context we
psilocybin and LSD and all of that how
is the science done and how is your
ability to write and talk about this not
just swamped by all of that do three
write about well I like everybody else
my image of LSD and psilocybin was that
sixties image of drugs that were being
used as party drugs very carelessly kids
taking them to go to concerts and things
like that I had no idea that long before
that as your clip showed they were a
very serious subjective they were
thought of as psychiatric wonder drugs
and when they escaped the lab and were
embraced by the counterculture is when
you got this backlash and we're still
kind of getting over that backlash but
it seems to be happening because the
research has been so compelling so far
it's not we haven't completed the
process of figuring out what they're
good for
did it the most promising studies show
the most promising studies show that the
drugs are very useful in dealing with
depression and there'll be a very big
phase 3 trial and it's important
understand how few tools psychiatry has
to deal with mental health problems in
general I mean the last major
innovations was in the introduction of
Prozac in the late 80s and those
antidepressants aren't working very well
anymore they're they're fading in their
effects there they only do a little bit
better than placebo and trials and
people hate the side effects they're
very hard to get off of did it change
your way of thinking because you tried
some of these things and I wish you'd
share with us what happened to you and
your wife and did it change your way of
thinking about it it did I did have some
what did you grab experiences I tried
psilocybin I was very interested in
duplicating my shrooms this is the
mushrooms and I was very interested in
duplicating what the research that was
going on at Johns Hopkins at NYU and I
had a guided psilocybin trip it was
under ground because I didn't qualify
for any of the trials and I worked with
a guide who was very talented very
professional and I had this incredible
experience of it was a fairly high dose
experience of my ego or a sense of self
absolutely dissolving until I saw myself
and I know this sounds paradoxical
spread out over the landscape like a
coat of paint yet I was still perceiving
this and it made me realize for the
first time and this is what I took away
from the experience is they we're not
all eye
Danakil to our egos our egos push us
around a lot our egos punish us they
defend us against new information from
the world and from our subconscious
feelings and suddenly I saw my ego in a
new light and that I was it was
something I could control a little bit
better now I might have gotten that in
ten years of psychotherapy I don't know
but I got it in an afternoon you write
in the book though that we don't die
well in this country and that maybe
psychedelics could help and we should
really legitimately think about that
yeah I mean look we have very few tools
to help people who have fear and anxiety
as a result of a terminal cancer
diagnosis prozac doesn't help them we
need to address what is really a psycho
spiritual distress and these drugs
appear to help with that and they're
part of this conversation we're having
as a culture about how to die and I
think that is really why they will be
approved because there's there's really
nothing else for people in that
situation and this really does appear to
help them reset and confront their death
with more of a sense of equanimity and
and perhaps a sense that their the end
of themselves their own egos may not be
the end of everything they contribute
you talk about them being improved that
we've seen with opioids and other things
that as a culture this gets out of the
box and runs all over the place there
are bad trips there are downsides to
people who self-medicate so how is that
possible - very important to talk about
the risks I looked at this carefully I
was a very nervous Nelly going into this
these psychedelic experiences I'm not a
I'm a very reluctant psychonaut but
they're relatively non-toxic less toxic
than alcohol
they're non addictive if you give a rat
in a cage a lever to press you know and
you put cocaine on it they will press
and administer cocaine until they die
put LSD on it they'll do it once they'll
never do it again so they're not an
addictive anti addictive the risks are
psychological when they're used
carelessly which is to say without a
guide sometimes people have really bad
trips most of which are just panic
attacks that people recover from but
there are occasional psychotic breaks or
episodes so people really have to be
careful and and treat them as the
powerful medicines they are alright
Michael Pollan thank you so much for
being here we appreciate it thank you
thank you very much